Olá você já se pegou evitando aquele
momento a dois ou simplesmente sentindo
que a intimidade com o seu parceiro ou
parceira não é mais a mesma você sente
que a falta de desejo está afetando a
sua vida dois hoje eu vou trazer um
vídeo que vai servir Tanto para você
homem quanto para você mulher eu vou
compartilhar dois chás e um alimento
incrível que são facilmente encontrados
e que podem melhorar muito o desejo
alibido
são afro zicos naturais estimulantes que
ajudam a aumentar o desejo sexual com
poucos efeitos colaterais a rotina
exaustiva o estresse do trabalho cuidado
dos filhos menopausa comou até mesmo uma
preocupação constante com as contas são
fatores que podem minar o desejo e
apagar a chama mas fique comigo que você
vai aprender a usar alimentos
afrodisíacos naturais entender como eles
ajudam a esquentar a relação vamos
começar então o primeiro item que eu
queria falar com vocês aqui é o no grego
talvez você já tenha ouvido falar dele
ou talvez isso soe como grego para você
mas Fiquem tranquilos porque estamos
falando do feno grego mesmo um produto
natural com propriedades incríveis
pessoal o extrato da semente feno grego
pode realmente dar um impulso na sua
libido ele também ajuda a controlar a
glicose e os níveis de colesterol além
de apoiar o ritmo cardiano melhorando o
sono e reduzindo o estresse Além disso
estudos indicam que seus benefícios como
afrodisíaco são válidos tanto para
homens quanto para mulheres ainda
segundo estudos científicos feno grego
pode ajudar a aumentar os níveis de
testosterona nos homens algumas mulheres
também relatam melhorias na libido e
bem-estar Geral ao utilizar o feno grego
Então como você pode incorporar o feno
grego na sua rotina você pode utilizar
como tempero ou optar pelo suplementos
mas a minha dica especial é experimentar
o chá de feno grego e onde encontrar
muitas lojas de produtos naturais vendem
o feno grego Apesar do nome complicado
não é difícil de achar apenas
certifique-se de comprá-lo de um local
confiável evitando sites suspeitos
produtos de má qualidade podem ser
adulterados trazendo riscos à saúde
agora para preparar o chá Você vai
precisar de uma colher de chá de
sementes de feno grego esmagadas
Lembrando que a medida da colher de chá
é aquela intermediária menor que é de
sobremesa e maior do que a de café meça
uma colher de chá Esmague as sementes e
coloque em uma xícara de água fervente
deixe a infusão por 10 minutos depois
coe e beba você pode tomar até duas
vezes por dia mas não exagere lembre-se
que tudo em excesso traz riscos para um
toque especial adicione uma pitada de
pimenta preta para um estímulo Extra
gengibre ralado ou uma pitada de canela
também são ótimas opções ambos com leves
efeitos
afrodisíacos agora vamos falar sobre
outro afrodisíaco natural que você
precisa conhecer a maca peruana talvez
você já tenha ouvido falar dela também a
maca é uma raiz poderosa
tradicionalmente usada para aumentar a
fertilidade mas tem também propriedades
que vão muito além ela é amplamente
reconhecida por suas capacidades
estimulantes sexuais tornando-se um
afrodisíaco bem Popular ela pode ajudar
na disfunção erétil e na disfunção
sexual em homens além de aumentar o
desejo sexual Em ambos os sexos Além
disso ela é famosa por equilibrar os
hormônios especialmente em mulheres
sendo eficaz no alívio de sintomas da
menopausa que frequentemente levam a
falta de interesse sexual pessoal a maca
pode melhorar o humor reduzindo a
ansiedade e depressão fatores que muitas
vezes contribuem para libido baixa Você
pode encontrar Maca Peruana em lojas de
produtos naturais e saudáveis geralmente
na forma de pó e é importante escolher
uma marca confiável que seja 100% pura o
sabor da maca é levemente picante
lembrando canela ou nos moscada o que a
torna uma adição deliciosa a várias
receitas Experimente misturá-la em sua
vitamina suco ou polvilhar sobre
alimentos como banana com aveia quanto a
dosagem use de uma a duas colheres de
chá por dia o que equivale
aproximadamente 5 a 10 g de macro
peruana lembre-se estamos falando da
colher de chá não da colher de sopa
agora a terceira indicação de afriso
natural é a que talvez você já tenha na
sua cozinha a nos moscada esse tempero
comum amplamente utilizado em diversos
pratos pode trazer benefícios que talvez
você não conheça embora existam poucos
estudos robustos os pequenos estudos
inúmeros relatos positivos sugerem que a
nos moscada Pode ser sim um estimulante
um afrodisiaco natural trazendo
benefícios tanto para homens quanto para
mulheres porém é é extremamente
importante ter cuidado com a quantidade
a nos moscada contém uma substância
psicoativa que é a chamada miristicina
miristicina que em excesso pode ser
tóxica pro organismo Portanto tem
atenção nunca ultrapasse a dose de uma
colher de café de nos moscada pois isso
pode causar batimentos cardíacos
irregulares náuseas tonturas boca seca
dores e até convul e alucinações mas
para aproveitar os benefícios
afrodisíacos da nossa moscada sem riscos
use sempre com moderação apenas pequenas
pitadas em suas receitas já são o
suficientes para preparar o chá de nos
moscada compre a semente rale na hora de
usar nessa metade de uma colher de café
pessoal é aquela menor colher que você
tem não confunda com a de chá estou
falando a colherzinha pequena de café
metade dela ou até menos você pode
começar com uma pontinha da colher de
café de nós moscada ralada e coloque em
uma xícara de água fervente deixe
infusão por 10 minutos depois é só coar
e beber o chá é interessante tomar esse
chá de noite após o jantar ou no meio da
tarde preferencialmente próximo ao
horário que você planeja ter o seu
momento o seu encontro íntimo e quente
com o seu passeiro ou passeira lembre-se
de não exceder o uso de uma vez por dia
desse chá Ok com esse simples Passos
você pode incorporar nos moscada na sua
rotina e descobrir seus potenciais
benefícios
afrodisíacos você pode começar com as
opções que passei e é importante não
usar todos os três ao mesmo tempo
Experimente um dos chás e veja como você
pode se sentir tome por um tempo e
observe se está ajudando se não não tá
nenhuma diferença tente Outro chá
natural teste uma de cada vez para
descobrir qual melhor se adapta a você e
sempre sem exageros e lembre-se se você
tiver alguma condição de saúde ou Doença
TR existente é essencial falar com o seu
médico antes de usar esses afrodicas
naturais regularmente isso é muito
importante para garantir a sua segurança
e bem-estar muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço um beijo seu
coração e você é fera